just after 11 a.m local time people in
kiev heard two lad bangs as ukrainian
defense systems shot down russian
missiles fragments of the missile
landing captured on security camera
narrowly missing someone on their
mid-morning walk
it followed an attack in the early hours
of monday
when what is thought to be an artillery
shell hit this residential apartment in
the north of the capital
maxim carries what little he has left
from the building
i woke up actually my mom woke me up
there was smoke and dust everywhere we
hid in the closet we thought that we
were being captured that the russians
were getting in through the door
police take pictures of the rubble
others look on
rescue efforts as you can see are still
going on the civil
brigades here the police and the fire
service
are still
looking through the building trying to
see if there's anybody else trapped
inside trying to see if there are any
more bodies inside
but the overwhelming sense is that this
is a civilian building there is there is
nothing
more that you can say about that look at
it it's a residential block an apartment
block
one resident had very strong words for
the russian president
it is a city he is just a jerk a total
jerk i've got nothing else to say
you see i've got no words to describe it
there's more fighting on the front lines
of butcher and appear
between russian and ukrainian forces but
the war coming into kiev although
expected is unnerving for many here
ukrainians wonder whether this is a
one-off or a sign of what's to come in
the battle for the capital
and imran joins us now live from kiev
imran first bring us up to speed with
what's been happening in and around the
ukrainian capital
well right now it's uh just after 8 pm
local time and i'm just going to get out
the way the camera and show you the
curfew has begun it's going to be
another very nervous night uh for the
residents of the capital key
particularly uh because of that uh
apartment block that was uh shelled by
artillery in the early hours of monday
morning
a lot of the residents now are very
worried that that a may have been an
opening salvo in the uh war for control
of the capital kyiv or
a lot of what military analysts are
suggesting is that it may have been a
way to keep pressure on the ukrainians
even as the talks uh were going on
whatever the reason for it it definitely
means that the people that are left in
this town and there's 50 percent
of people left in this town 50 have
evacuated and we are seeing more and
more evacuations continue but they're
not coming from um they keep the capital
cave itself they're coming from places
like bucharpin
places that are front lines where the
russians and ukrainians are fighting
hard with each other uh those people are
coming here and then they're getting out
via the central stage train station so
although uh the curfew is on it's gonna
be a very nervous night
for a lot of the people left
in this city despite the tension imran
and the fighting the two sides as you
say are still talking it seems do we
know what they're talking about and
whether any progress has been made
well there's been a real change in the
type of language that we've been hearing
in the last 24 hours before the talks
began both sides were saying uh yes we
are talking there are things we are
talking about and we and the russians
actually said uh we're looking forward
to releasing a joint statement those
talks began on monday and they came to
an end with very little progress being
made in fact uh one of the people who's
involved in talks he's the presidential
adviser and uh chief negotiator if you
will actually said uh and he's the chief
ukrainian negotiator yeah she said
although russia realizes the nonsense of
its aggressive actions it still has a
delusion that 19 days of violence
against uh ukrainian peaceful cities is
the right strategy
he's also
said that it's something that the
communication is being held yet it's
hard so the language has changed the
last 24 hours there was a tiny bit of
optimism uh the day before the talks are
on the day of the talks both sides have
retreated back to their positions
ukraine very much defined and the
russians very much saying uh that
they'll continue their operation uh now
the talks
this is the fourth round the last three
rounds of talks have concentrated on
humanitarian corridors on getting aid
into besieged areas there was a hope
that they wouldn't talk about something
other than that it looks like that
hasn't happened both sides have walked
away from the talks and this joint
statement that the russians said that
would come today never came imran thank
you for the update imran khan life force
in ukraine's capital kiev